let's talk about the man on my shirt
right here mr larry elder he's getting a
lot of momentum he was on tucker carlson
last night you know obviously there was
this ridiculous incident with the with
the
monkey woman
and the egg and it's like you don't want
anything like that to happen but at
least it did bring attention to his
campaign that's good obviously the
democrats are nervous because they're
bringing out the big guns
obama and kamala and i think biden is
doing something today supposedly and as
i said yesterday look if it's gavin
newsom barack obama and kamala harris
and now joe biden versus larry elder me
and scott baio
i like our chances we're going to be all
right um so first i want to show you uh
these two headlines this is this is just
really like if you want to see how
perverse really perverse and dishonest
the mainstream media is these are two of
the headlines from the los angeles times
this is the los angeles times the same
los angeles times who by the way as you
know said that larry elder is putting is
the black face uh on white supremacy
okay so look at these two headlines now
you all know what happened the other day
this crazy woman that you're seeing
there with the pink gorilla mask she
started screaming uh racist remarks and
cursing at larry and a whole bunch of
other people were saying really horrific
things at larry as he was just walking
through venice because venice has become
a drug den and a homeless encampment
basically uh so she's throwing a
negative she then assaulted one of the
one of the security guards and look how
they framed it
larry elder cuts short venice homeless
encampment tour after
hostile reception
and then look at the second one
now first off the first one hostile
reception the implication is that he's
getting a hostile reception like from
sane people right like like he got there
and he said something that then they
were hostile about but these were crazy
drug addicts and maniacs but the import
what they're trying to do is frame it is
that he's somehow controversial that
that first one's not terrible actually
but i want to show you the second one
which is really just
it's just remarkable
lapd is investigating altercation
involving larry elder at venice homeless
encampment
what does that sound like to you if you
didn't know this story it sounds like
larry elder picked a fight probably with
a homeless person at a homeless
encampment that is so deeply dishonest
it's it's just it's pure
[ __ ]
bull [ __ ] that's what it is and the el
the the la times at this point is a
white supremacist newspaper i can only
deduce that between you know basically
calling him a white supremacist lying
about this violent attack not saying
that you know what where are all their
op-eds about the racist base of the
democratic party that's throwing eggs
and attacking a black candidate you know
where where's all of that so i guess the
la times is a white supremacist
newspaper there's sort of no way around
it uh that being said i still am feeling
good about what's happening with the
recall and i get it you know i really
want to make this point clear well two
points here actually first off i get it
the deck is stacked against us this is
this is largely a democratic state and
modern liberals no matter how many times
you whack them in the head with reality
uh it's very hard for them to go oh all
of the reasons the state sucks the high
taxes high regulation bad schools bad
roads homelessness drug use etc it's
it's hard to believe that that could
have anything to do with the way i've
been voting right uh this is like sort
of what i would say to bill maher if
he's ever brave enough to put me on the
show it's like you rail against all of
these things all day long you're a good
liberal right my good
my good liberal friends what happened to
my idw good liberals they've all gone
silent on everything that matters
and i do want to give a complete
exception to that on ben shapiro and
jordan peterson who have been as good as
ever but the liberals have just
completely completely collapsed um so
let's uh also show you because we're
talking about the media and larry elder
here this this video from yesterday now
i know some of you have seen this
yesterday
but rose mcgowan was on the show rose
mcgowan is the girl who in effect
single-handedly took down harvey
weinstein she walked through the fire
said this man raped me it it started
uncovering all of the other horrific
rapes and sexual assaults that harvey
weinstein did two years ago he was the
biggest bad guy in america right like
that was the thing it started the me too
movement
you know believe all women all of that
stuff well now rose mcgowan is coming
out and saying that gavin newsom's wife
jen newsom three months before the
harvey weinstein story broke when they
knew it was going to break that she
contacted rose on behalf of harvey
weinstein's lawyer
to see what could make the story go away
and she's saying she has receipts do you
think that maybe that's worthy of the
news covering it right now that the
california governor who's under recall
that his wife was shilling for harvey
weinstein to silence
someone who was sexually assaulted by
harvey weinstein like do you think that
maybe that's newsworthy maybe well first
in case you haven't seen it here's rose
jennifer seabold news him i think that
is her name yes she called me and she
set up a meeting with me to meet her
someone in brentwood and i actually went
and i got very like creeped out and i
saw her sitting where her sister meet
her and i looked at her and i i turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me
when is this when is this just this is
about
six months before the new york times
article in weinstein that i set up broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
therapist board member the
lawyer for
long-time lawyer of hillary and bill and
clinton and weinstein
won david boyce so this woman i don't
know some blonde lady named with the
last name of newsome cold calls me and
it's like
david boyce wants to know what it would
take
to make you happy
six months before the weinstein story
what do we take to make you happy which
you took as for those that might be
playing along a little bit slowly
i i don't know because i don't know if
it would be fiscal remuneration i don't
know i like absolutely nothing would
make me happy
what would it take to make you happy
this guy was raping you for years raping
all kinds of people he's the most evil
man in america the entire system uh
tells you how awful he is you know he
should burn in hell blah blah blah
believe all women it started an actual
revolution in this country in some
respects uh but now that this story is
not being covered now i do want to
clarify two things here uh in that video
there she said uh six months before the
story broke she later clarified with me
yesterday after we taped the show that
it was three months before the new york
times ran the harvey weinstein story so
that's just it's not that important but
it's worth mentioning uh and also if you
watch the full interview originally
jennifer newsom wanted a in-person
meeting
with rose rose actually went saw her
sitting there and then didn't go and
then this was all done on a phone call
rose is saying she has receipts and i'm
not saying i haven't have not seen
receipts
but where are you media where are you
media or
gavin
jennifer come out and say she's a liar
is she a liar
where are you gav come on